hi everyone thanks for showing up um so
this is the long title that I put in the
forum as months ago and then I figured
out well what this is a bit I don't know
would this really attract people and I
was like a bit too late for that so
obviously you're all here but I would
say what I really wanted to talk to you
about and I think that's true for no
matter what level you are right now in
your career is how you grow how you grow
in your role in your career how do you
make choices as you grow what do you do
when you're faced with choices that
maybe you didn't expect and a little bit
as you heard about me I'm a freelance
data scientist analytics consultant you
can find me on all sorts of places
why can I talk to you about how you can
grow so I think I did a little bit of
growth in my career as well so I started
out in data science as a professional
data scientist managed to skip the
junior level I moved into senior role I
became a technical lead I then became a
team lead and then I became a director
of data science and then I went
freelancing so that's how I ended up
here and throughout that journey and I
think throughout your journeys as well
and I would say in any points of their
career you need to make decisions for
yourselves but maybe also in more
advanced levels need to support people
as they make their decisions in their
career which might be different than
yours and you need to so I think this
topic is really relevant for you no
matter at what level you're currently
are and I think it's also really
interesting conversation so if you're
into this some of these things I'd love
to chat with you later as well if we
don't have enough time in the Q&A and
other than these things that I did for
money I also did some things not for
money I run our ladies Berlin I also run
a meet-up called women and machine
learning and data science berlin for
about a year now and i ran the first our
conferences our conference in in berlin
this year saturday berlin you could say
i'm all are but actually most of my work
these days i do in python for the last
several years has just said i really
like the art community and i
and grew a lot there I found a lot of
mentors I found a lot of support I found
a great place for me to grow and I will
mention these things later on and so now
I'm the core member of our forwards
which is the our foundations task force
for diversity and inclusion and I
recently started volunteering also with
gnome focused disc since I think like
the recipe inclusion it really is
platform agnostic in language agnostic
and this year of also or end of last
year I started volunteering as a mentor
in a peer-to-peer mentoring for free
network unpair that's in Berlin so this
is just to show you that your growth
isn't limited to what you're working and
if you want to ask me later how I find
time for all of these things start with
one hour a month and it'll take you from
there
and now why did I want to give this talk
why is it like isn't it's just all
obvious as I just listed there's all
these career steps and there's things
you can do but my feeling is when you
start talking to people and I say it
also when I was interviewing and then
later and when I was hiring you're
hiring for like a senior data scientist
and you're like what does data science
mean here and what does senior mean here
what are these things we are not well
defined and part of it is because we are
still a new business function some of it
is not well defined for other business
functions and some companies are still
young and things are still kind of
disorganized so this is always a good
question to ask and it's always a good
topic and I'm definitely not the first
one to think about it many have people
who have already been in data science
probably have seen any one of these
evolutions of the Venn diagram of the
data scientist I think these are all
really similar efforts to discuss the
topic that I'm going to discuss today I
would just say that from what I learned
through our time is the Venn diagram is
not the right visualization for this so
I'm not gonna use them today but I do
want to talk to you about a few topics
namely bees what are a career tracks
what are skills what's levels skill
levels and then what are your hard
skills and your soft skills why
something that not often is a feel is
talked about as mindset because I feel
it's very personal and then of course
what resources you might have to go and
you know grow throughout all these the
skills and tracks and how do you
actually use all of this information
that I'm going to give you in practice
so
let's get started where's the data
science part it's hiding a little bit in
the skills so it's mostly in the hard
skills so quite a lot of this is true
for a lot of career tracks and
development I would say I would say for
data science I think it's and maybe for
almost any job you're a person you're
gonna need in order to do it well and to
grow you might also want to grow in your
soft skills I think there's something
specific in soft skills that are good
like maybe really unique to our role not
in a sense that it's only for our role
but let's say for our role they're quite
important maybe for other roles or not
and yeah and let's dig in and see how it
goes
so tracks and I particularly picked this
picture because people tend to think
very linearly especially that maybe
previous generations I think in our
generation it's already kind of not that
linear but somehow it still goes like
junior professional seniors it doesn't
really feel correct for how we actually
live out our professional lives so while
it tends to and I call them doubt tracks
so like these are the titles that are
available but then make your own path
through them and how to make these
choices we will we will discuss in a bit
so in general there is yeah you get you
start not being good at something and
not having experience and then you get
better and then what
so then comes you should go into
management or not but what if you don't
what do you like to do what you're doing
so I want to like maybe again formalize
the discussion a bit this is more is to
give us language to talk about these
things and to kind of understand later
on how the different skills could apply
to this so what are our tracks
so beyond senior you could move into I
would say expert and principal and you
could be senior expert I've seen
companies do senior senior senior
there's also so level it depends on how
developed the organization is and like
and also how to build a profession is
right if you see like people with like
20 years experience in Java I hope
people get to that with data science
soon having always had the title data
science because obviously the profession
is not as young as we would like to
think and then there's management and
management seems as Lisa at least for me
and early in my career seems a bit aloof
and its management is like what do you
Pete manage the people do you make the
decisions do you do what what is
management if you have an IFC study
management so like I should know but
like in in work it doesn't mean what it
means necessarily right management in
practice as a manager it's not what it
is to study management is a science and
so I kind of wanted to engage say that
as a management you could also choose
different types and like I said I was a
technical lead and then I was a team
lead those are different types of
management so there is project
management there is making the trends
and it's really like making sure that
things are organized and are going to
get done and and having a scope of what
is the tasks that we need to get them
then there's functional management which
is for me is really translating
strategic decision into like functional
decisions into functional tasks so
you're you're given a goal that is
overall we want to achieve something as
a business and now you're like my
function data scientist marketing would
go ahead and do something within that
and I haven't written data science as a
function here because I it really
depends on your Gaydon ization your act
sometimes it would be centralized it
would be a function of its own and
sometimes there will be product data
science marketing data science and all
of that and there's technical which is
about how you translate it into choosing
the scope of the technical tasks right
not just what it is you want to be
achieving but as a feature but also like
what what technology will we used to do
this how much legacy cold will we choose
to battle while we're doing this and
there's of course people management
which if you want and I've originally
when I was a technical manager I wasn't
a people manager so you could say I
don't want to do one-on-ones and
meetings but I still want to move into
management and those are things you
should be thinking about and also
engaging the organizations you may be
working with about how to say what it is
you are interested in and what it is
you're not and there's a score strategic
management which is about really setting
the strategic goals and all of these are
different types if you're early on
startup as a manager you might be doing
all of them and we're in bringing hats
and as organization grows you might
choose to actually like give away some
of these tasks and specialize and
dedicate more time and effort to them
and then you might have make a choice
about which one you want to pursue even
though you have experience in all of
them
let's move on to skill levels the only
thing I really want to say about this
because it's just like an intro to all
the skills to me skills are about how
what you can do execution and and how
you can help others do which is
leadership to me and then there is
within each one's you'll see in a moment
there is what you know but there's your
influence so to me those are both in
your scope of your work so how do I see
levels and again a lot of this is kind
of like basic HR it's not necessarily
negative to data science if you're new
you're novice you're in the execution
track right now for a level you don't
have much experience and your focus is
to get to know how to learn do a task
like your this is what you have in front
of you if you're learning you're already
are gaining some basic knowledge and
you're you're maybe you're already
working on a project not a single task
in front of you but you know a few tasks
in a row and then if you're a proficient
working knowledge maybe more of a team
focus how are we as a team getting
things together what are we delivering
if you're highly proficient then maybe
you have very extensive and advanced
knowledge and your scope might be within
the team and stakeholders as an expert I
would say broad extensive knowledge but
you and your infants should be across
teams and as what and again experts
senior expert versus principal don't
catch me on the title and the name
itself I would say there's broad
extensive knowledge and you should have
an impact across the organization now
all of these are not relevant to me at
to your track you could have broad
extensive knowledge and an impact across
the organization and not the met senior
manager because you are have it in one
specific skill but not in 20 okay and
you come maybe with a with a PhD and two
postdocs and there's something that you
are an expert on but it doesn't yet and
you could have an influence if maybe
someone empowers you and gives you the
voice also in the organization but you
might not necessarily so this doesn't
translate to where you are on the on the
track and and what's what's your title I
would say now let's get to the to the
data science part what are I think and
this is similar to all those Venn
diagrams
sizes this is my thought so far it keeps
growing
DevOps wasn't there a year ago so I
think I would say take this home add to
it and there's also I think it's really
important to discuss these things try to
extend it and here I'm gonna give you
like just a few examples of what it
could mean because if you are growing or
supporting someone growing in this I
want you to remember that each one of
these things are something that as a
data science you can do or not do you
should maybe know that it's part of data
science and you should evaluate if you
do once it's do file if you're a skill
there or not and that each one of these
is a whole world of skills why because
this is what I think is mathematics
statistics and algorithms and that's
just like again I just wrote a few
things down this is not an any way an
extensive list there's quite a lot in
here not everybody who is an expert in
Bayesian is and is an expert and I don't
know feature engineering and simulation
it's just how it is right so this is
about how you then go into a specific
skill and try to think about what how
how good am I really add it so I would
like you all to think about these skills
and think for yourselves or support
others and then thinking about how good
are you at it go back to the levels what
is your level in this and be honest
because it's for yourself
I'm not saying tall you're like how bout
you imagine saying for yourself where am
I on this what are all those skills that
I still think part of data science I do
think data engineering we don't need to
be data engineers as if necessarily but
we do work with them they are a big part
of the pipeline and it affects what we
can and can't do and having awareness of
what the data engineers even if they are
a separate function are doing is really
important for you as a data science
because you are then able to come and
ask for things and and participate in
this interface with that much better so
an ETL I just kind of hope that
everybody kind of if these if you're
doing big data gets to but then of
course maybe not necessarily user in
load management
maybe that's less important but maybe if
your code is really really problematic
you should know that they could help you
because they are doing it software
engineering also quite a lot of things
in here and this is just a few but you
start with just writing code and the
thing is you think about these things
separately or a try to separate them out
but you can't really do the statistic
math part at work as a data scientist if
you can't at least write some code like
you're not gonna do this in your head or
pen and paper right so obviously all of
these things in your work are integrated
but you would like I would like to start
thinking and evaluating how good I am
separately not how good am it so how
good I am it you know using Jupiter and
and pandas and numpy versus how good I
am it actually like delivering insights
or picking the right motor or
understanding what are the doing design
experience experimental design and so on
of course you do all these things with
code but code is just one part of it
then I would say the data scientists
communication data visualization super
important super important to understand
it in depth I would say I feel like this
is kind of a maybe it's my pet peeve not
people not a lot of people I think get
into it enough it seems to be they're
just excited or data science but you
could and you could see people around
you in the organization who are using
the stuff the data you provide them with
and plugging it in a very misleading way
and making very wrong decisions so
please get into data visualization just
a little bit I think it's really
important there and of course now the
emerging as a separate I would say skill
set already because of the scale we're
working at and because of how it already
emerged as a function on its own in tech
there's DevOps and security yeah not any
data scientist might name maybe needs to
know that moratorium but if that's your
background and if you understand this
you could be a great data scientist in
supporting that and deploying and
supporting the data scientists and how
they deploy things in the cloud and
supporting DevOps with doing analysis on
how their work is going so it's still a
really valuable type of work and now
comes you know the very small topic of
business knowledge and this is I just
wanted to put out there because this is
I feel a lot of people who are coming
from academia or from computer science
whether it before before you're a
programmer or a researcher they're
always coming like I want to learn about
business like that's that that's the one
I want to know and all those Venn
diagrams what is business it seems it
seems like it's almost as elusive as
management and and it is it's quite a
lot and I think it is I would say first
and if it's a lot about is is your
domain so if you have research and
ecology and you're going to
in an echo tech company than great you
have a lot of the main knowledge but you
sometimes were a biologist and you end
up working in the car industry and you
need to get some car industry knowledge
in order to be effective in what you do
and to research it well but on the other
hand it's also an I put PR and HR and
all these things you're working on
organization that has all these
departments and they are all making
decisions and there's lots of data
around and you can support quite a lot
of decision making in organization if
you understand how the organization
works and also if you are planning maybe
becoming a lead later or seeing that if
we had two more people in this team we
could reach a lot more this year but
then how does staffing happen right so
it might not be the thing you do but
every day but it could be down the line
it could be what your manager needs
supports on on how to how to do this so
these are still things that are part of
our work as a professional next is soft
skills so this was really hard to do I
used quite a lot of resources to try to
get my head around this but I hope this
is valuable I find it useful as I said
as a tool for myself so there is a I
would say first of all this is like
really private but it's between yourself
what is your work ethic what is your
motivation and different people choose
different jobs because of this one of
the reasons to leave academia might be
because of this it might not be because
you might have a comfortable job but you
don't feel motivating you mow don't feel
the sense of urgency and urgency that
there is in the startup could be so
knowing what it is for yourself and
maybe this is less of a level of how
good I am at it and more of it just what
is what is it that I'm into and maybe
when it comes to flex it may be there
are things you can grow maybe you
weren't so flexible you used to be doing
so it's a certain singing stirring way
and you realize that that this scale of
team it's not going to work you have to
change you have to adapt then there is
feedback communication and collaboration
so communication I said I feel it's key
data validation is the hard part of it
but being effective being able to do
public speaking and to inform other
people at your company about what you do
in a way that's useful to them and in in
general knowledge sharing and I would
say that documentation that's a
communication skill that's a really
important communication skill
and there are lots of good examples I
think around in the open-source
community if you don't have in-house
good examples there is stakeholder
management
you can't just work in a bubble it's not
already I'm doing our team is doing
these cool things you have to know how
to build relationships with the people
who rely on what you do or can rely on
what you do and you need to do it well
if you want to perform well as a fungus
a business function and this might be
not all things and that's true for all
of these skills as I said before that
you do yourself but as a team as a whole
these are the areas that you need to
cover someone should be good at it if
you're building a team feedback is
really important within within for I
think anyone like in any kind of thing
in life but I think in data science I
can see it as not something key being
able to give each other feedback on it
works a lot of our work is very creative
being able to do performance evaluation
which maybe some of us haven't done
before and being able to grow and learn
right if someone really told you the
truth and you could really hear it then
you could really come back to this and
this and make different decisions based
on that and how you're going to advance
and then collaboration that's the
internal relationships but also really
important how to handle disagreements
maybe even try to track how do you
handle disagreements regularly and if
you see that kind of you're always this
maybe you go back to your flexibility
point of like maybe I'm always kind of
like trudging in and I need to kind of
like sometimes let other people you know
when the argument maybe it's about the
mood the next day or the next hour after
a disagreement right there could be
quite a lot of things and they all
impact what we get to do delivery this
actually came to me from from employees
of mine that were like this is missing
this should be on here like we shouldn't
be just evaluating how you know what it
is our skills are and not for ourselves
and not for in general ways we like also
about what we do and how well we do it
how well we are able to break it down I
would say dealing with ambiguity is a
really interesting one like and that's
really common for for juniors but also
for people in transition that like what
happens when you don't know what to do
or you need to talk to someone or just
how both how comfort you are with this
comfortable you are with this and also
what actions can you do when you are
like
find for yourself so this is also a
little bit about exploring as I said
more personal things but they're also
just about like knowing how to break
down dependencies and prioritization
things it could be very hard in the
beginning or very hard if you're
switching to join your organization or
working with the new stakeholders
economic thinking like okay I I came to
this project because I really love this
type of model and I want to do this type
of research but this is going to take
how much time and what do we actually
need to deliver and maybe D prioritize
things that were your reason to assign
yourself to the project right and and
again and maybe not maybe your choice is
I need to find a place where I can do
this
so knowing your priority is knowing the
project priorities this type of thinking
and in this type of economic thinking
project management I put it in here I
feel like it's mostly covered by the
previous one but I wasn't sure so I just
wanted to make sure that I'm not losing
the interfaces and the scoping which I
think is really important and I feel
like you could really develop on this
without necessarily developing on all of
the previous ones at the same speed in
product management it seems to me you're
kind of a well-defined kind of scheme
that has lots of tools that you could
really get ahead leadership really
important if you do want to move into
that elusive management track how again
something that mentor once told me that
he doesn't know it's not for him it's
not about how much how many decisions he
gets to do but how much influence he has
in the organization and that seems to me
like the most what I don't understand
what Jesus said but it got me into like
what is influencing what is that how do
you do that so it's really about being a
role model about thinking about cultures
and values and how to promote those it's
a whole different type of work but if
you're able to promote curiosity and
innovation you can have a lot of impact
on the data science team and data
science and the organization process
design decision making as I said there's
quite a lot in here and of course people
management which is really important
it's not for everyone but if you do it
like you're really influencing other
people's lives do it well so learn about
it read about it and so on and I'll get
to resources in a bit and then of course
strategy mr. diederich thinking
I even think I put strategic networking
in there that's also really useful
there's quite a lot about how how you
think in the bigger sentence not and it
might not be relevant early career or
maybe it is because if your goal is to
be an astronaut then maybe you should
start early but you kind of need to
figure these things out and again assess
what you are kind of honestly assess
where your team where your team as a
whole it's also a good way to think
about the team as a whole and what
you're missing so yeah that's a little
bit about skills and I hope I gave you
some some information and food for
thought there I want to move to another
topic and that's mindset and I think
that doesn't get discussed a lot because
it's really nobody's business but your
own so it's not really something that a
manager can bring but it's like I'm
concerned about your mindset because
they don't know your mindset they really
don't they might be concerned about your
performance it might be they might be
happy about it and you might be unhappy
because your mindset is different and at
the end that's for me a really personal
question and something that I take into
account whenever I'm thinking about do I
really want to grow right now how much
effort you want so like I said it goes
back also to what the levels were
because you could be an expert but have
a mindset that doesn't allow you to
perform at the expert level and the
other way around you could be not not
necessarily not have a lot of knowledge
but have a mindset that allows you to
have wider influence that your team
right so this is why this is again not
necessarily very linear so I tried to
come up with a few again with some
research of my own I think there's
different mindsets you could be at they
could be over a period but also in a
specific day you might like while you're
really driven to learn and you're taking
courses and you're learning quite a lot
on a specific day you might just want to
contribute and get something out so it's
kind of more for me a way to personally
go through this process and make sure
that I still hit my goals or notice it's
like maybe I need to change my goals
maybe I need to update them so how do
you get all of this sounds great like
let's turn all of these skills and let's
be an expert at you know all of them or
if you're particular at five but if you
want to be the you know the perfect full
stack well-rounded data scientist and go
like it's like here's a list it's a road
map right but I think how do you
actually do that like how do you get
better at
at business when you're a junior and you
don't necessarily know it and how do we
get better it's to keep thinking when
you're now a manager and like you
haven't had to done this before you used
to be writing code all day and now
you're you need to make the ggx
decisions so I think there are lots
first of all there's like where do you
get to use resources sometimes it's
on-the-job getting stuff done signing
yourself up to a project where you need
to use a model that you haven't used
before is a great way that's a resource
on its own sometimes you work and
provide you with things you could get
courses you could get all sorts of
trainings get sent to conferences and so
on you could do it independently on your
own time you can find a community and
you can contribute to open source
projects a few ideas a few things and
again I wanted to at meetups and open
source just to clip go back and clarify
in a little bit also with my story of
why I ended up volunteering at open
source project and running meetups is I
just tried to connect them to some of
the skills if you run a meet-up
you can get leadership experience even
if you're not a manager at work if you
give a talk at a meet-up and you commit
to it that's a delivery you get feedback
as well you get to practice giving
feedback to others these are all things
that you could do by going to an hour at
one month once a month to a meet-up and
the same with open source projects you
can learn a lot about law and legal
issues by going to to by trying to
contribute to a fine and like get get
involved in all of these things in
practice how do I actually do them and I
think I gave you a little bit throughout
I think you should know your own skills
so you need to think for yourself and
you should know your mindset and you
should try to adapt to that so go
through this and then you should first
what I always tell people at the end
when I run through all of this is there
to me there are two main questions and
if you have time for more than greats
what's your passion don't drop it
because then you won't stay in the field
you will burn out you will not be happy
so the reason and it could it be
updating it could be that the reasons
that got you in today to science it's
not the reason you're now like you're
not spinning off in the DevOps and you
never imagined you'd be into that book
that's perfectly cool like but like know
what it is you're passionate about and
where you want to keep growing and then
know your blind spots because a little
bit of improvement in the places where
you have no clue about would help you to
perform overall pitch
you better to appear better to
contribute your team and then explore
discuss with other people and I guess
this is just an overview of everything I
mentioned and you can find it I get it
[Applause]
okay thanks a lot Noah for this great
talk we do have time for questions hi
thank you very much it was a really good
talk I was wondering if you have based
on your experience everything I have
done if you know if it's easy to say the
biggest challenge is / differences that
leadership in the data science teams has
to have in comparison to traditional
software engineering career paths so I
say it's it's I would say temporarily
it's not an episode where data science
is now it's a new business function and
not everybody knows how to engage it and
not everybody feel comfortable it comes
to feels comfortable about it this is
where like developers were in the 90s
left in the startup in the Indicom boom
right it was a new profession suddenly
lots of people are flowing in not
everybody had a lot of experience in and
specifically and the organizations were
shocked by it not everybody was ready to
go digital right so I think in a way you
could learn a lot from developers
experience in and especially people who
have been there and finding mentors so
we've gone through that could really
teach you so I don't think they're
necessary that difference but they're
definitely offset there right now in a
different place I still think there's
lots of lots of room to to grow there
beyond that where there might again I
don't know if mathematics is scarier
than programming I don't know like at
the end is how how do people see what
you do and how clear it is where it
interacts in the organization I'm not
sure it's all that different yes more
questions
[Music]
I was wondering about your thoughts on
how to fight sort of being forced to do
all kinds of stuff on projects just
because you have a wide set of skills
well for example if you have people with
a like sort of shorter like smaller set
of skills and you have someone to wider
set of skills the guy with the wider set
of skills will not guy someone you don't
want to be you'd like to yeah in the end
in the end for stuff to be done somebody
needs to do it and you sort of get
burdened with all the stuff that's so
that's why I mentioned that discuss
because I think it's really important to
talk to your team and your manager about
it and it could very well be that you
can try to way stop doing it does
there's no one else but maybe if they're
willing to take on the underlying goals
that you help them learn a few things so
that more people know more of the
generalist so it's really about when you
work in the team and that's it's about
discussing how we get it done as a team
and it could be that right away it's not
possible it could be that you choose to
go someplace else where there's not so
much dependency on you but it could be
there within the team you can figure out
a way out of it and talking about these
things what you in knowing what you want
what's bugging you and being able to
talk to your manager and to your team
about it and how do we as a team get it
done so that I'm not always the one
doing it I think that's a good place to
start but yeah at the end if those are
the tasks and there's no one else and I
mean do you want the job that's also a
decision to make as you grow again thank
you very much for the talk the question
I have cause I figured that is more
maybe when you're already in your career
when you're already on a path what's the
best way of starting out do you have any
tips or hints on that yeah so I mean
luckily I think for a lot of people now
that wasn't available when I started
there like a lot of degree programs and
so on you could like learn data science
now in ways and I don't know there's the
data science toolbox which is a really
good framework on how to get into data
science that I think a lot of people a
lot of courses are built around that
there's a lot of transition courses that
are available and there's I know people
who did completely with MOOCs with like
online course
is so it really depends also on your
level I think there's a lot of resources
paid and free I tried to list and give
some ideas and if you want like specific
ones I can also try to mean find me
after I can say at least the ones I know
but I can't recommend like I'm not an
advocate there might be a hundred that I
don't but there are definitely a lot of
materials out there there's lots of
blogs going to meetups joining a
community finding the first project to
just it maybe you're more hands-on maybe
just going just starting to work on one
specific thing is a better start but
there I think there's quite a lot of
resources like I think finding resources
in the problem and and and as well as
fire defining which one to go for first
and I'd say go back to your passion like
why are you again I'm trying to get into
this try to find is something that
enables you to do that first thing last
question
[Music]
hi very insightful talk and I had to
really run to the toilet so I'm not sure
if somebody already asked this question
how did you transition from director of
data science back to freelancing tango
in in the traditional mindset of here he
it feels like you step down right in the
trade you like it to me so to me again
and that's my priorities for me and it's
a new way also career paths are also at
the end a very personal journey there's
a lot of stuff I miss I miss people
management I miss doing a lot of this
type of work
but I really wanted to prioritize the my
open source work and that meant working
in less than 100 time 100 percent and
that's quite hard to do as at that level
and that's also a choice so if I'm
wanting to be a core member and a
project I need to have time to do it and
if it's not a part of my job then I need
to change my job or I need to prioritize
different thing right so for me was as
ideal and it's it's a lot of personal
decisions and it was about how much do I
want to work on what things and that led
me to need to make that move thank you
thank you again nuan thank you
you